Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this on Arrow
the streets were literally on fire.
A lot of big plot threads were resolved and
we’ve finally got some images for the finale
next week.
It was basically mass pandemonium.
I’ve also got some news on the trailer for
the Flash TV Show.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow Videos every week.
In the next couple of weeks after the finale
I’ll start doing more Flash and DC bonus
videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So real quick before we get started.
The Flash rumor is that the trailer for that
will air during the Arrow Finale next week.
So you’d better watch.
We’ll also find out when it’s going to
premiere in the fall too.
Okay, back to Arrow.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
But here are my top 5 WTF moments.
Number 5 - Oliver Has Failed This City
It was a nice twist on the line.
He had to say it at some point.
Stephen Amell even commented in a recent interview
that he hadn’t said it on the show in a
long time.
It’s mostly a Season 1 list kind of thing.
Speaking of which, he also said in a Q&A he
posted to his facebook page, that the List
would be coming back soon.
They’d start doing more list flashbacks
eventually.
In the context of this episode he was just
talking about his failure to deal with Slade
when he had the chance.
Because we don’t know what happened during
the final battle on the Amazo boat we can
only guess.
But it sounds like he was able to incapacitate
Slade when he shot the Arrow into his eye,
but didn’t follow that up by chopping his
head off.
In case you’re wondering, based on Merlyn
taking down the Super Soldier with the arrow.
I think all you have to do to kill one is
land a sufficient head shot.
But if you want to be sure, just chop their
heads off.
Like you’re a Winchester killing vampires.
Number 4 - Malcolm Merlyn Returns
We’ve known he was coming back for a long
time now, but his grand entrance was so very
Captain Jack that I cheered really loud at
my TV.
John Barrowman has this swashbuckler pirate
charm that’s just so much fun to watch.
He’s playing Merlyn, a very very bad person.
But did you see the smile on his face when
he said, “I’m Her Father.”
I think that was John Barrowman just having
some fun.
He’s basically just trying to take Thea
away.
I love that he’s still able to land some
jokes while the city is burning and a mirakuru
soldier is bashing him against a wall.
That’s Captain Jack for you.
Thea did have that line, how are you still
alive?
And even though it wasn’t a reference to
Torchwood.
I still kind of took it that way.
There was this interview he did where he revealed
the Arrow producers explained Merlyn to him
as a stable villain.
As in like horse stables.
Meaning they’d trot him out every once and
a while.
Implying that he would never truly die.
So take that with a grain of salt.
But there’s also rumors that Merlyn will
be the Season 3 big bad.
Also, I saw a lot of you commenting on Twitter.
That gun shot Thea made was a fake out.
She wasn’t shooting Merlyn.
They just did that so you would wonder whether
or not she would.
The mirakuru soldier probably just got up
behind Merlyn and that’s who she was shooting.
Number 3 - Slade Watches Rome Burn
I loved that Nero reference he made.
I don’t ever think Slade would let anyone
catch him singing.
But I bet he was singing inside his head.
Maybe evil tinkerbell shado was singing to
him.
Who else laughed when Isabel was like WTF
is Shado?!
Remember she did that, because it’s going
to come back in the finale.
Addressing the fact Slade is hallucinating
Shado.
Slade also revealed his true plan.
To turn Starling City into ashes.
We’ve been debating on who this other person
is that Slade has to kill.
Brother Blood even said, “The Person You
Love Most”.
Part of me wants to think he was talking about
the city itself as a person.
Just because I don’t think he would love
any of the women on the show more than the
others.
Like he loves his sister equally as much as
he loves felicity, sara and laurel.
So the women cancel each other out and by
default, all you’re left with is the city.
So let’s go with that.
Number 2 - Felicity Takes Down Isabel
Who else feels like this is building to a
Felicity VS Isabel fight in the finale?
I loved that cut between scenes though.
Her asking Diggle where she was straight to
Felicity ramming her with the van.
Interrogator Felicity to the rescue!
I was a little confused though.
What did Felicity do to Isabel that would
make her want Felicity dead?
Diggle was the one who killed her, and Oliver’s
father was the one who threw her away.
So let me know why you think she wants Felicity
dead.
It might just be the smug way Felicity treated
her.
Mirakuru has a way of turning insecure people
into psychopaths.
I really love it when they give Felicity scenes
that are off type.
Like normally she’s sitting at a computer,
so it’s so much more rewarding to see her
win a physical fight.
Like during the Clock King episode when she
took the bullet.
I just hope that she doesn’t have to take
too many bullets in the finale.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment.
Amanda Waller Is Going To Destroy Starling
City To Save The Rest Of The Country.
I actually expected those soldiers to be the
League of Assassins but facepalm, of course
they wouldn’t roll in like the cavalry.
It’s all ARGUS, and even though she said
she was using a drone strike to drop bombs,
don’t be surprised if the Suicide Squad
shows up too.
I feel like any episode she’s in becomes
kind of a backdoor Suicide Squad episode.
Too bad Harley Quinn isn’t on the show yet.
Streets of Fire seems like her kind of party.
In the end I totally expect Team Arrow to
pull off the 11th Hour save and avert that
drone strike.
I also think that we’ll end up with a situation
where it’s everyone but Slade versus Slade.
Even Isabel looks like she’s seeing him
in a different light.
I’m so hoping they let Felicity Kill her,
but I feel like she’ll need Sara’s help.
There was also this really interesting thing
that Stephen Amell said about the finale.
He was asked to describe it in 3 words.
And he said, “Wait, He’s Where?”.
I think he was referring to Slade and Oliver
learning that he was on the Island.
Even if he’s not on the Island, it implies
that Slade will end up somewhere really unexpected
like the Foundry.
But that feels a little too predictable.
One last bonus moment too.
Isabel Kills Brother Blood.
There were a few things about this that surprised
me, mostly that it was not Laurel and that
it happened in such a short time frame.
The show had foreshadowed a conflict within
Team Deathstroke.
Like the idea that Evil always turns on itself.
But it feels like they should have waited
for the finale for Brother Blood to try and
help Team Arrow out.
It just feels like they rushed that part.
But I guess it was just so that Roy could
be back for the entire duration of the finale.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was?
Felicity hitting Isabel with the car, Oliver
twisting his line on himself or Brother Blood’s
death?
Before I do my review I have a couple big
plot points I wanted to address that they
didn’t cover in this episode.
The biggest being Oliver’s Son, will that
come back in the finale?
And if it doesn’t will you all be pissed?
I’d be disappointed, it such a huge reveal.
Why would they tease it so late in the season
if it wasn’t going to become an integral
part of the finale?
Could that baby be the person Oliver loves
the most?
Even though he doesn’t know about it, Slade
could just be assuming that if Oliver knew
the baby existed it would be his greatest
treasure?
Then there’s the League of Assassin’s.
We know they’re coming back, we saw the
image of Nyssa.
But when Sara explains why she came back,
she says nothing about bringing friends back
with her.
So either Sara doesn’t know they’re coming
or the writers just wanted it to be more of
a surprise.
So they cut a scene out of the episode where
it did get explained.
That actually happens sometimes.
Where scenes that explain things better just
get cut out because of time constraints.
And then there’s the relationship of Team
Arrow with the Police Force.
Clearly Quentin’s Lieutenant goes along
with Team Arrow helping because of the super
soldiers.
But will that cooperation continue in Season
3.
Quentin is back to being a Detective and the
commissioner is dead.
So I’m expecting everyone to get bumped
up the ladder and Quentin, now a full on Team
Arrow member, will be in charge of the police.
Making it a lot easier for him to cooperate
with Oliver’s missions.
Lots of big questions to answer in the next
week or two.
Overall the episode was a solid A. Everything
about it was great, the Set Design was the
best I’d seen all season.
This was a huge undertaking with all the extra
debris, cars and literally setting the streets
on fire.
Then you have the stunt work.
There were a few pauses in the action, but
essentially the episode itself was one continuous
fight scene.
It’s one thing to coreograph a fight between
two people in a small space, but there were
multiple fights going on in scenes across
the entire episode.
I’d be willing to bet they spent more time
and energy on these last two episodes than
on all the other episodes this season combined.
And it was worth it.
A lot of other similar shows are now being
judged by Arrow’s example.
From the character development to the set
design to the action.
Let’s talk about the acting really quick.
In my opinion, from an acting standpoint,
Laurel, Oliver and Brother Blood tied for
best performance.
You expect Stephen Amell to be the best because
he’s the lead actor.
But Kevin Alejandro really killed it for his
final scenes.
I got this really twisted Batman vibe from
him.
Like Batman put on his mask to face his fears.
It think that was aactually a line from Batman
Begins.
It’s just that the character is clearly
looney tunes and Oliver just has that moment
where he’s like “you are fucking kidding
yourself if you think you still get to be
mayor after all this”.
I’m crossing my fingers about Oliver’s
Son next week, but otherwise I fully expect
all remaining plot threads to be tied up.
I also think we’ll get a nice teaser for
Season 3.
And that trailer for the Flash tv show.
If there’s anything important you think
I left out of the video just write it in the
comments.
I’m posting my Q&A video tomorrow, be sure
to subscribe to get everything.
Here’s a direct link to it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here to catch up on everything before
the finale.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!